opportunity lurks where responsibility
has been abdicated in 2016 dad put a
video on YouTube which was Professor
against political correctness and it
just turned our lives upside down he'd
been talking about HR and how HR
departments would be the death of
universities and at one point he came
downstairs talking about the death of
universities and my mom was just like
just put it on YouTube after that video
went up we had reporters line up outside
my parents house the Metro which was the
newspaper I read on the way to school
had a comparison of my dad to Hitler on
it now when that kind of thing happens
we can kind of laugh at it it's like
it's mainstream media and then my dad
was getting invited on podcasts and
doing interviews and my life changed
from all the jobs I took from him in a
really positive way